the first black woman to lead the
country's largest local Prosecutor's
Office is apologizing after a husband
pointed a gun at black lives matter
protesters this video shows the early
morning confrontation in a southern
California in Southern California
yesterday it happened outside the home
of Los Angeles County DA Jackie Lacey
she faces a primary election today
Carter Evans reports on the heated
encounter Baltimore porch
this is how Los Angeles County District
Attorney Jackie Lacey's husband David
greeted protesters outside their home
Monday morning never in our wildest
dreams did we think we would have a gun
a cocked gun with her husband's finger
on the trigger pointed inches from my
chest black lives matter organizers Luna
Abdullah was standing on the porch
during the confrontation she says
protesters have tried to meet with Lacey
for more than two years and she's faced
several protests outside her home if
they won't engage us when we show up at
their public events what choice do we
have
Lacey has been the target of regular
protests due to her handling of
high-profile cases in 2017 she did not
prosecute police officers who fatally
shot an unarmed black man three years
earlier and she later charged Democratic
donor Edie buck in relation to the death
of a man who died after two black men
were also found dead of drug overdoses
in his home buck has pleaded not guilty
to the charges
Lacey apologized Monday for her
husband's actions he wanted to me to say
to the protesters the person that he
showed the gun to that he was sorry but
she also took to the podium to defend
her record people are going to be angry
because you either did file a case or
you didn't file a case but your job is
to uphold the Constitution to uphold the
laws well I'm just glad that nobody was
hurt that no shots were fired but I also
think it's not a good idea to go to
someone's house at 5:30 in the morning
and be on their physical porch I heard
mrs. Lacey say later that she and her
husband were actually very very afraid
they actually was here they were if they
cross the property line that's that's
someone's porch changes things a little
bit Carter Evans we thank you for that